Lauren is with us in Bakersfield
California hi Lauren how are you I'm
doing very well Dave thank you for
taking my phone call sure how can I help
well I have some really good news okay
this morning at 8:30 I made my last
payment on my house yay and my rental
house yay
so as of this morning I'm completely
debt-free Wow
what's your household income um maybe
150 160
Wow you're well on your way to be a
millionaire good job man congratulations
thank you appreciate that I guess Mike
my question is is that just freed up I
don't know roughly forty thousand
dollars a year for my wife and I for
real yeah how do we take this this
equity that we have and really make it
work for us that's a great question
well you're what we call a baby step
seven person you're a hundred percent
debt-free and there's nothing left to do
now but build wealth and be outrageously
generous and so what we teach folks to
do is of course we want to max out all
retirement that's available that is
already done okay boom done easy then
what I want to do is just sit down and
do a household budget that is reasonable
not doesn't need to be tight but doesn't
need to be like sloppy loose but just
something reasonable Sharon and I to
this day do a budget and our income is
way larger than our budget okay but we
just do a household budget what do we
want to spend including you know some
travel and some miscellaneous stuff
nothing nothing extravagant and then
whatever amount of money is left over
that let's call it 40,000 for four
giggles okay okay look whatever amount
of money that's left over that then we
apply a formula to it so that anytime we
get a raise we use those same
percentages or anytime I get a in my
case I get a check in from a publisher
you know
some royalties come in on a book and I
open up the mailbox and I have a good
day that day you know I just apply that
same percentages to that check and
here's the percentages you want
percentages that address taxes are you
on salary only where everything's
withheld yeah okay then you can you
don't do this complicated you can just
say whatever comes home you need to
divide it among three categories as a
percentage you need to have some fun
with it you need to save and invest some
of it and you need to give some of it
okay
now at our house that giving would be in
addition to our tithes we automatically
tithe 10% off the top and like with a
publishing check they don't withhold
anything on that that's self-employed
income so I've got to hold out you know
forty percent for taxes so fifty percent
of that money's gone in taxes and tithe
okay then I got fifty percent left over
and I'm going to apply some kind of a
percentage along those what what portion
of that fifty ten or five or or thirty
five or whatever is going to go into
investing what portion am I going to
spend and enjoy a nice trip with my wife
or let her buy a purse that's silly or
me buy a gun that she thinks is silly or
whatever right okay that kind of stuff
and then and then we're going to invest
and we're going to give in addition to
our tithe so always be giving always be
enjoying and always be investing and
just apply a percentage formula to it
and then it's a it's on autopilot for
you you're always doing all three and
you should always do all three
congratulations man ding ding way to go
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]